all right let's start today with sort of
an audience question I think it's a good
one this is exactly the type of question
I love to answer a viewer who I guess
goes by the name smash wrote to me about
the 2020 election and said dear David
you believe the 2020 election was not
stolen and there is no evidence to the
contrary what would you accept as
evidence what would it take to convince
who it was stolen hope you can answer
these questions thanks this is a fair
question because I would be a hypocrite
and I don't want to be a hypocrite in
front of all of you fine folks if I
demanded that sort of uh consideration
from others what evidence would change
your mind and then refuse to answer or
explain it myself and remember very
often if the answer is there is no
evidence that would change my mind
you're not really thinking so what
evidence would change my mind the first
thing whenever you have a conversation
like this and maybe this will be useful
to some to some people when we say
evidence what are we even talking about
and so to be very clear
for me to be convinced that there was
um an orchestrated voter fraud or
election fraud wherein Donald Trump was
the real winner but Joe Biden stole it I
would need evidence of some kind of
systematic voter fraud so the fact that
we found a bunch of Republicans you know
a dozen or so who either voted twice
there's the guy who's a junior and he
voted for himself and for his dad senior
who is no longer alive uh or we find you
know a Democrat that voted legally via
absentee ballot and then died by
election day like none of those things
are proof of systematic fraud and not
only do they not rise mathematically to
the theft of an election from Donald
Trump it's also just like a random
person okay so that that's the first
important thing we are looking for
evidence of systematic voter fraud here
and I would even go further and say
systematic voter fraud that would have
materially changed the results in at
least one state not even the entire
thing but at least one state okay there
are two types of claims that the
proponents of these conspiracy theories
often make
the first type of claim is that
sometimes the big lie people will make a
claim that something happened and that
thing did happen but it just isn't
actually voter fraud even at the
individual level never mind some kind of
systematic voter or election fraud so
I'll give you an example they say
hundreds of thousands of people were
registered in two places or usually it's
like at the state level they'll say tens
of thousands of people were registered
at two different addresses that's not
evidence of any kind of fraud it's not a
crime it's really common that when
people move they remain registered at
the old place if they showed up and
tried to vote at the old place they
would be allowed to
but they also might be registered at the
new place as long as you don't vote
twice there's no issue and there's no
crime so all of the allegations from the
right about things that are true but
aren't actually a problem those I don't
consider evidence of voter fraud because
they're quite literally not fraud
another example is they say State
legislatures changed voting rules
without altering the state constitution
well that's true but that's legal you
might not like it you might disagree but
under the public health emergency of
covid in 2020 there were state
legislatures that voted without altering
the state constitution to expand
absentee ballot or whatever
it's not a crime it's not illegal and
it's not evidence of voter fraud so
that's one bucket things that happened
but aren't actually evidence of voter
fraud those don't change my mind all
right then we get to the claims of
um anomalies anomalies anomalies your
preference okay like for example
hundreds of thousands of people didn't
really vote but they're they show up as
having voted
there has been no proof of those claims
there just has no proof of that so if
you can bring to me proof of some kind
of a systematic requesting and
submitting of absentee ballots by
someone and you've got to tell me who
the someone is without the knowledge of
the actual voter
in More Than This Minute number of cases
where it seems to be a paperwork error
then that I would consider that uh
substantial
if you were in and it can't be
we don't know who did it
and we don't know who the people are but
here's three people who say I got an
absentee ballot but I didn't ask for it
okay there were places that just sent
them out that's not fraud either okay so
if you can come to me with evidence that
listen we have found an IP address from
which a hundred thousand absentee
ballots ten thousand twenty thousand
something were requested and Mass
sent somewhere intercepted by someone
who filled them all out and sent them
all in oh now we're talking about
something we do not have that
um proof of people voting in multiple
locations that I would be interested in
not just your registered in two places
not illegal Trump's Tiffany Trump that
applied to Tiffany trump it applied to
Mark Meadows that's not actually against
the law if you had actual forensic
digital evidence of voting machines
being used in a nefarious way you know
you've got Mike pillow talking about the
machines and you've got all these claims
about Dominion did this no proof a
smartmatic did that no proof okay if you
present actual evidence that we can
subject to a digital forensic specialist
who can say hey you know what here's
proof here is proof of the manipulation
here's 10 000 people who try to vote for
Trump
and their votes were counted for Biden
and that has not been presented okay
felons voting in large numbers on
purpose mobilized by someone right like
five felons voting illegally because
they either didn't know they weren't
allowed to vote or even deliberately
right that's not actually evidence of
fraud at any real scale it wouldn't make
a difference in even a single state and
there's no evidence that it's
coordinated by anybody in the election
fraud sort of mode that these
Republicans claim the other thing is you
have to explain to me
how the relationship between the
population of a state
the known number of registered voters
the number of people that turned out and
very importantly remember the people
that voted presidential and down ballot
there is complete coherence between the
presidential vote counts and the votes
for Senate or house Etc if there were
some coordinated voter fraud of this
kind you would expect that if they just
messed with the presidential voting
alone there would be this completely out
of sync uh um uh these out of sync
results between presidential and Senate
or house or whatever the margins are
completely reasonable in all of these
and the Republicans never like to
explain well
I won my election legally on the same
ballot in which it was stolen from Trump
oh okay so the ballots only some of the
votes were fraudulent but the down
ballot stuff it's completely incoherent
one of the important themes or ideas I
think that's worth mentioning here is
something that Dr Stephen Novella writes
about in his I forget the name of the
book it's like Skeptics Guide or
something like that it's called anomaly
hunting and very often you will hear
actually the perfect example is the
umbrella man from the JFK assassination
and Dr Novella talks about this in his
book
after the assassination of JFK
pictures turned up with a guy holding an
umbrella on the grassy knoll or you know
on the side of the parade route at which
John F Kennedy was killed and you had
people who started to say it was a sunny
day
there's no reason someone would have an
umbrella and so they start to build up a
picture that goes something like what
are the odds that we have a presidential
parade and the president is assassinated
and we're told this story of a lone
gunman up in the window and there's a
guy with a huge umbrella on a sunny day
right alongside where JFK was killed he
must be involved because that's so
anomalous
but as Dr Steven Novella explains
the question should be a different one
the question should be because that does
make it sound nefarious in some way but
what if we you reframe the question and
you said what are the odds that at a
presidential parade
with so many attendees you find someone
who looks out of place for no
particularly nefarious reason when you
ask it like that a guy with an umbrella
doesn't sound so Sinister and of course
we later found out that the guy with the
umbrella the umbrella was a political
protest I believe it was a political
protest against uh maybe Robert Kennedy
I don't remember exactly so you have to
also understand that you know if I said
to you look at this thing that happened
that's a one in an eight million chance
you would say oh my God that's got to be
something is going on there something is
acting on that one in eight million
things are so rare New York City has 8
million people that means every single
day
there could be a one in eight million
occurrence and it would be
mathematically expected and so a lot of
this stuff that these people look for is
sifting through data to find something
that sounds unlikely but the reality is
that when you have however many million
votes we had 170 million 180 million
more less something
um you can find seeming anomalies and
they don't really mean anything okay so
hopefully that gives a sense of what I
would accept as proof that the 2020
election was stolen uh Donald Trump's
lawyer Christina Bob is lawyering up and
willing to cooperate with the Department
of Justice my how quickly things change
when you are one of Donald Trump's
lawyers remember
Maga really means making attorneys get
attorneys Salon reports Trump attorney
lawyers up and says she's willing to
cooperate with doj and Mar-A-Lago case
at least one member of former president
Trump's legal team has hired her own
lawyer and allies are urging another to
follow suit Trump attorney Christina Bob
and Trump attorney Evan Corcoran
affirmed to the justice department that
Trump did hand over all those classified
records from Mar-A-Lago but prosecutors
say that that wasn't true
the response was incomplete after the
FBI searched and found more documents
Bob who by the way is also an anchor on
right side broadcasting if you can
imagine the incestuous nature of what's
going on there Bob has since hired her
own lawyer and made it known to Trump
allies she is willing to cooperate and
be interviewed by the justice department
colleagues have also urged Corcoran to
hire a criminal defense lawyer because
of his response to the subpoena
according to the report he insists it's
not necessary Bob told the Washington
Post when asked whether she was
negotiating for a sit-down interview
with the doj I'm sorry I'm not allowed
to talk about it now remember Bob's
relevance in this entire thing that is
in this article where it says quote Bob
signed a document affirming that Trump
handed over all the documents that are
responsive to The subpoena after a
diligent search Corcoran then met with
doj officials and made a similar
statement they then found that that was
not actually true
now another important aspect of this is
that Bob
um helped push Trump's legal challenges
after the election and has insisted that
she believes the document she signed was
accurate but she also told right side
broadcasting she's not actually acting
as Trump's attorney while serving as a
custodian of Records she's only doing
the custodian of Records thing so listen
here's the bottom line on this even if
you are a trump supporter how can you
justify him taking the documents what is
your explanation for what he was
planning to do with them and why did he
lie about them having been returned did
he not know and you believe Christina
Bob is the one who lied well Christina
Bob says she signed off on it because
she believed the documents were returned
so who told her because if it's not
Trump who said uh lie and say the
documents were returned and if Christina
Bob was just doing what she was told who
came up with we are going to claim
the documents were returned uh the next
part of it is are any ex of the
explanations that anybody has given
believable right the documents were for
Trump's library that he doesn't care
about the documents were for Trump to
write his Memoirs even though Trump
doesn't write the documents were for
Trump to read even though Trump doesn't
read the documents were uh uh
Declassified telepathically right before
the FBI planted them none of the stories
make sense and what we're learning is
every single one of these people is in
over their heads think about the number
of red flags here and what it sounds
like is that Christina Bob realized
people are going down this is a very
serious criminal investigation the FBI
knows that we didn't really return the
documents my name is there saying the
documents were returned and she is now
trying to distance herself but the theme
is being Trump's lawyer really doesn't
go well it often doesn't go well
financially
although Trump's lowest newest lawyers
are collecting money up front which is
smart of them to do and it often doesn't
go well criminally or in terms of your
legal career either Christina Bob has
lawyered up who will be next find me on
Twitter at dpacman and let me know
so I was briefly on a reality show
called the dish and this is really
pretty funny
um this is a show where Mama June
Shannon is on the Treasure Coast of
Florida she's trying to help my friend
TV star Adam Barda sees the opportunity
of a lifetime there are Frenemies
there's drama there's all sorts of stuff
going on for our Howard Stern fans tan
mom is a part of it it's just completely
crazy and I appear on the show and the
dish is our sponsor today and it's all
just delightfully ridiculous and I would
love for you to check out the show let
me know once you've seen it what you
think about my reality show debut I'm
curious to hear from you that's
davidpackman.com dish
Georgia Republican Senate candidate
Herschel Walker is very much against
abortion abortion is murder abortion is
evil abortion is killing and it appears
as though Herschel Walker paid for a
girlfriend of his
to get an abortion the last 24 hours
have been a historic and historic
implosion for Herschel Walker and you
are not going to believe what is going
on but the real question is always is
are Republican voters so depraved that
they won't even care but we'll get to
that in a moment Herschel Walker is now
being accused and you know accused this
sort of like it's only the word we use
because it makes him such a hypocrite of
paying for a girlfriend's abortion the
woman has receipts and a get well card
that she says Herschel Walker sent to
her here's the article about this from
The Daily Beast and the headline the the
top points are a Herschel Walker says he
wants to completely ban abortion he says
it's murder he says there should be no
exceptions for rape ancestor the life of
the mother a woman who asked not to be
identified told The Daily Beast that
when she and Walker conceived a child
while dating in 2009 he urged her to get
an abortion the woman said she got an
abortion and that Herschel Walker
reimbursed her for it she was able to
support the claims with a 575 receipt
from the abortion clinic a get well card
from Herschel Walker and a bank deposit
receipt including an image of a personal
check from Walker for 700 the reason for
the difference the abortion costs 525
but the check is for 700 she says it's
because she ballparked the cost to
Herschel Walker after looking up the
cost online
The Daily Beast was able to
independently corroborate details of the
claim with a close friend who she told
at the time who took care of her in the
days after the procedure the woman said
Walker who was not married at the time
told her you know it would be more
convenient to terminate the pregnancy if
you believe it's murder do you murder
out of convenience Herschel he said it
was not the right time for him to have a
child it was a feeling she shared but
what she didn't know was that Walker
already had had an out of wedlock child
with another woman earlier that same
year asked if Walker expressed regret
for the decision she said no he didn't
ask why she came forward she points to
Walker's Hardline anti-abortion position
I just can't with the hypocrisy anymore
we all deserve better so listen
I am not against Walker paying for an
abortion assuming he was not coercive it
sounds like he was urging the woman to
have an abortion but I'm primarily
against the disgusting hypocrisy of this
these people and Trump is the same Trump
I mean listen I I'm not aware of trump
paying for anybody's abortion and
pressuring them to get one it would not
be at all a shock if Donald Trump has
sometimes pressured someone to get an
abortion and paid for it but that it's
not something I can speak to right now
but Trump's story about oh I'm so
against abortion so against abortion
since being 68 years old and up until
then I was very much in favor of a
woman's right to choose this is one of
the things that would Doom Herschel
Walker's campaign
if not for the sad fact that many of
these Republicans don't read the news
and if they do they will assume this
story is a lie and if they believe the
story they won't care
here is a montage from Ron filipkowski
of Herschel Walker very powerfully
against abortion
whoa
he's also said if a baby is survived in
abortion he uh voted to uh deny that
baby Medical Care and how extreme can
that be he's a pastor and I said thou
shall not kill you know he's uh seemed
to be relished on a woman killing her
baby and he's a pastor so that's the
reason I think most abortions after 15
weeks what's your stance you know I
believe in life I'm a Christian I
believe in life and I and it is strange
that my opponent and no one is talking
about that he seemed to be really
excited about a woman killing her baby
what is his term he's not right to have
the doctor and the patient and the
government in the same room and I said
do you not realize that there's a baby
in that room too
the life and I'm not going to apologize
for it and you know and I thank you
she'll be in the States but if I had
vote right now it'll be yes trains
because I say I'm a Christian
right now you say you're a Christian
and they said her so what do you think
of he asked me all these questions I'm
like did I not say I'm a Christian
that means you're supposed to be
pro-life I thought anyway you guys get
the picture so let's see what this does
to the polling of Herschel Walker the
good news is that after Herschel Walker
was very very very slimly leading Rafael
Warnock the last three polls and four of
the last five have Rafael Warnock back
ahead but it is very tight it's within
the margin of error we're talking about
under a one point spread so let's give
this a week and see if this is finally
the nail in the coffin that we've been
hoping for for Herschel Walker's
campaign a guy who has no business
whatsoever being in the Senate but it
gets even better my friends after this
news came out Herschel Walker went on
the Sean Hannity program and then it got
really crazy so in order to try to
defend himself
Republican Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker went on Sean Hannity's
Fox news program last night and this is
all about this explosive story wherein
although for months and months and
months Herschel Walker has been saying
I'm pro-life no exceptions for rape
incestor health of the mother never
never ever ever an abortion it's a
murder and now we have learned that
Herschel Walker allegedly paid for a
woman's abortion after urging her to get
one when she became pregnant during
their relationship some years ago so
Sean Hannity goes into rescue mode and
as you know Sean Hannity has tried to
rescue Trump in these interviews and it
hasn't gone particularly well here Sean
Hannity tries to help Herschel Walker
and it goes really really poorly now the
funny thing about the interview is
it's almost impossible to even tell
whether Herschel Walker is denying the
story because he's so incoherent but if
you I'm kind of kidding like if you
listen carefully he does deny it here
he's asked by Sean Hannity do you know
the woman in question and he says I have
no idea
he has no idea whether he knows her and
then he goes to talk about the Border
it's beyond parody start with The Daily
Beast Herschel I mean serious
accusations that in 2009 that you paid
for an abortion first question do you
know the woman that is making this
allegation
I have no idea no idea but it is a
flight out lie and he has no idea
whether he knows her uh and now you know
how important this seat is the seat is
very important that they'll do anything
to win this seat lie because they want
to make it by everything else except for
the true problems that we have in this
country is this inflation the board are
wide open Crime they don't want to talk
about that so they're making up lies now
because they need this Georgia seat
right I want to encourage anyone out
there let's not let them take this seat
go go and vote yeah that's this is the
the entire story really is about the
fact that Democrats want the Border wide
open and this is how they're going to
achieve it
um Herschel Walker then asked about
whether he sent the money and he says I
send money to a lot of people I just
like to help people then he says he
doesn't really know anything about it
and then a picture of the signed card
pops up on the screen every minute
element of this rescue interview attempt
just going wrong for Herschel Walker
because right now for them to come out
with total lies I think that's nice to
us so they're claiming that on September
12th of 2009 that the woman has a
receipt for an abortion they're claiming
that five days later on September 17th
you sent a 700 check and that you sent
it in a get well card the get well card
it looks like it's included with your
signature on in the article have you
seen it and is that your signature
uh I haven't seen it uh it's on the
screen now maybe he can't see the screen
you know I can tell you uh I send out so
many get well or send out so much of
anything but I can tell you right now he
sends out so much of anything before we
continue I love how Hannity is is like
listing all the evidence begrudgingly
yeah he's like listen Herschel they've
got the bank transfer receipts and
they've got uh the get well card and it
looks like it's your handwriting and
they also have the receipt from the
abortion and they have pictures of you
on dates with the woman and they have
you in an audio recording urging her to
get an abortion no this stuff isn't true
is it Herschel it can't possibly be true
I never asked anyone to get an abortion
I never pay for an abortion and it's a
lie and I'm going to continue to fight
you know yeah I'll tell you that's what
they want they want this seat but right
now they've energized me even more and
they're not going to take the seat so
they better work it even harder because
they've jeopardized my kids they've
jeopardized my family they think they
can threaten me they think they can
scare me right now all that done is it's
energized me more that I'm gonna fight
and win the seat for the great people of
Joy all right so anyway not exactly
great uh Alibis here from Herschel
Walker but a wild wild story and just
completely failing I mean listen if you
found that convincing let me know it's
it's not seeming particularly convincing
to me but let me know if you found it
convincing and this is only one of two
Herschel Walker scandals in the last 24
hours
Republican Georgia Senate candidate
Herschel Walker's son
has now brutally turned on him and is
denouncing Herschel Walker on the same
day that a woman has come forward and
said pro-life Herschel Walker
impregnated me
urged me to get an abortion and then
paid for the abortion we already talked
about that here is Christian Walker a
sort of known influencer in fact the I
guess he's called the legitimate son of
Herschel Walker I don't really like that
term because it you're not illegitimate
just because your dad doesn't want
anything to do with you but anyway he's
called the legitimate son of Herschel
Walker and he has had enough of Herschel
Walker he's had enough of his own dad
even though Herschel Walker is a mega
nut and Christian Walker is a mega nut
Christian Walker tweeting yesterday
quote every family member of Herschel
Walker asked him not to run for office
because we all knew some of his past
every single one he decided to give us
the middle finger and air out all of his
dirty laundry in public while
simultaneously lying about it continuing
I know my mom and I would really
appreciate if my father Herschel Walker
stopped lying and making a mockery of us
you're not a family man when you left us
to bang a bunch of women threatened to
kill us and had us move over six times
in six months running from your violence
I don't care about someone who has a bad
past and takes accountability but how
dare you lie and act as though you're
some moral Christian upright man you've
lived a life of destroying other
people's lives
how dare you
that's Herschel Walker's son and this is
not about getting in the middle of what
is an obvious family problem
this is about the disgusting dishonesty
and hypocrisy of Herschel Walker framing
himself to the Republican Mega nuts of
Georgia as the Christian guy
as the moral guy as the pro-life guy
whatever
and being the complete and total
opposite the only question that remains
and I don't have the answer to this we
it's a it's a question it's a predictive
question we will see in November is we
know what happened after the Trump
Access Hollywood tape
nothing he was elected president of the
United States
are the Georgia Republican voters going
to look away again because they just
really don't like Democrats like Raphael
Warnock
um or is this going to Doom Herschel
Walker's campaign let me know what you
think and all of these clips we've
played we will have on our Instagram
which you can find at davidpackman show
don't forget that the best way to
support the David Pacman show is by
becoming a member which gives you access
to the Daily bonus show The Regular Show
with no commercials you also get access
to our entire Archive of every episode
dating back a really long time and
plenty of other awesome membership perks
go to joinpakman.com and use the coupon
code better 21 for a huge discount
joinpakman.com
today I'm going to be speaking with
Andrew koppelman who is a law professor
at Northwestern University and also
author of the book out today Burning
Down The House how libertarian
philosophy was corrupted by delusion and
greed it's not just the delusion it's
also the greed which I think is
important really great having you on I
appreciate it it's a coalition it's a
college very happy to be here so okay I
mean I think maybe the way to start
talking about this is I is a progressive
on the left I uh air on the side of
small L libertarianism when given the
choice between
authoritarianism and libertarianism
unless there's a really good compelling
reason to get a government or some
Authority involved I say stay out of it
and of course there are so many
exceptions to this that's like my
general idea but when we talk about
libertarian philosophy in the way you
talk about in the book you're not really
talking about what I'm talking about
which is a small L libertarian leaning
is that right
that's right I I think that the Common
Ground between us is the idea that if
the point of government what we should
be aiming at in government is giving
everybody the means to decide for
themselves how they're going to live
their lives and uh now that is a very
new idea in human history uh for most of
human history the point of the state was
the greater glory of King Sargon or at
the Triumph of the two religion or the
Triumph of the master race or uh you
know something other than the
flourishing of the individual so really
the argument between I you and me and
the Libertarians is an argument about
strategy how does one go about building
a world in which people are free to live
as they like and what's distinctive
about the Libertarians is a very strong
view that the way to assure that is to
[ __ ] the state to limit the power of
the state if only the state were
radically limited only protected our
persons and property and did nothing
else we would be Freer when you talk
about the delusion part it would be
great to hear a little bit about what
you mean you know I've experienced
conversations with Libertarians that
devolve into you know strange
conversations about everybody makes
their own Road and puts tolls on it or
you I'm sure you've heard in popular
media the way that these conversations
often go what is the delusion part that
you you're talking about well the
delusion is the idea that in order to
live the lives that we want that we can
do without uh the kind of big powerful
state that we have had uh certainly in
the United States in the last uh 100
years uh because there are quite a lot
of things that keep us from living Our
Lives the way that we want which do not
consist of either the government or
other people encroaching on our property
uh I mean one good example is covid uh
covet didn't violate anybody's rights
but the reason why we were able to beat
it back is because government raised an
awful lot of money with taxation
Libertarians hate taxation big
government gave a lot of money to
private investors who would not have
invested the money themselves in
developing a vaccine and it was a
partnership between government and the
private sector that made it possible for
us to go back to something approaching
normal life without that I think that we
would still be hunkered down in our
houses fearful of death every time we're
in a room with a group of strangers yeah
that that's really interesting you know
oftentimes the word coercive comes up in
conversations with with Libertarians and
you know whether it's applied to taxes
or business regulations or the IRS at
the end of the day if you just refuse to
pay your taxes eventually someone
arrests you and you could potentially
you know the this concept of coercion it
seems to me that that if you step back a
little bit from politics and just think
about anthropology and uh so many other
fields of study there's this idea that
once you get to a group larger than 150
often is the number that's mentioned 150
humans you sort of need to have some
decisions made from the top in order to
be able to grow as a society beyond that
and and so even if there is a little bit
of coercion don't we need a little
coercion in order to be able to to live
as a modern society
well I think that it's a mistake to
think of it in terms of size the
question is not a little coercion or a
lot of coercion but the right amount of
coercion so one example that I think
that libertarian uh you know libertarian
philosophers who are who I engage with
primarily in the book because
libertarianism is political philosophy I
think well if there's a minimal thing
for the state to do it's to keep people
from harming other people well one way
in which I we can harm other people is
by pollution uh you and I can agree to
have me make a product that you buy and
it makes me better off and he makes you
better off and that's the great thing
about markets but in the if in the
course of manufacturing the thing that
you want to buy I poison all the
children in a three-mile radius of my
factory then now I'm not adding value to
the world now you and I are conspiring
to hurt a bunch of innocent people well
so how do you fix that you're not going
to fix it with private lawsuits because
it's hard for each of the victims to
prove that they've been harmed the only
way to do it is with regulation that
limits what you can put in the air and
if you want to have that kind of
Regulation you need a government with a
huge staff of scientists to try to
figure out which chemicals are harmful
and which aren't you cannot fix this
problem without big government you talk
in the book as you mentioned about
figures like Robert nozick you talk
about Hayek we hear a lot about iron
Rand and the Koch brothers and all of
these different players that are often
Loosely described as as Libertarians of
some sort of flavor
modern libertarianism has been
influenced the most by who of these
characters or others that you engage
with in the book
well the common sense libertarianism
that an awful lot of people uh hold the
sort of you know Common Sense minimal
State idea really owes the most to a
Murray rothbard who is the most
important political philosopher you
never heard of he's the one who uh
shaped the early libertarian party he's
the one who persuaded Charles Koch to
start funding libertarian causes he's
the one who met young Robert nozick when
he was a graduate student and got him
interested in this stuff he also
mentored Randy Barnett who was The
Mastermind of the legal challenge to
Obamacare
um and uh so I think he's the most
important of the lot and I talk about
all of these people in the book uh which
is basically describes the way in which
libertarian thought has evolved over
time and he was fundamentally an
anarchist but uh you know one way of uh
taking his line of thought is to which I
guess people who are not willing to go
all the way to anarchism have gone is to
say well whatever else we do let's
minimize the power of the state and the
authority of the state and while that's
still not uh the official line of the
Republican party it has enormous
influence there Trump didn't talk in
broadly libertarian terms but you look
at what actually got passed when the
Republicans had both houses and the
presidency they did a big tax cut for
the rich they nearly took Health Care
away from 20 million people and they
gutted administrative agencies like the
EPA which I just goes to the thing I
said at the beginning about a coalition
libertarianism draws two different kinds
of people one is philosophers like
nozick who have a story to tell about
what a just state is and the other part
of the coalition question is business
people who'd like to be able to hurt
people without being bothered by the
police
yeah I mean but I'm curious in terms of
the modern Republican party because
you're sort of mentioning a little bit
about the the rhetoric versus the things
that were passed under Trump in those
those couple years
in the modern Republican party kind of
in the Maga direction that that it has
gone it seems nationalism is a big thing
it seems as though
authoritarianism when it is convenient
to you it has become an increasingly big
feature is there any real traditional
libertarianism that is still kind of
left or prominent in the modern
Republican Party
well the libertarianism that remains
prominent is a desire to constrain the
state the formula of the Republican
party for a long time has been to talk
populist while doing big favors for Rich
supporters and so you see that in uh
what continues to be the target of uh
the Republicans the modern
administrative State uh
the administrative state is really
inconvenient for business so you tell
people you tell ordinary working people
that you know I'm going to protect you
from these arrogant government
bureaucrats who don't respect you
and then you limit the capacity of the
bureaucrats to deliver clean water and
safe workplaces and clean air and so the
consequence is that then you tell uh
your ordinary working person look I
saved you from the bureaucrats and as a
consequence that ordinary working person
does not live long enough to meet his
grandchildren yeah I mean I guess the
the desire to limit the power of the
state seems to be only in ways that
those on what's perceived to be the left
want to have the state involved right
because in many other ways in terms of
clamping down on uh media Outlets that
you disagree with or when it comes to a
lot of these social issues abortion and
gay marriage and the the right to fire
someone for their perceived sexual
orientation in those cases they seem
okay actually using the power of the
state and uh what we saw under the first
Trump Administration we'll see if
there's a second Trump Administration
but they already learned that they could
get away with
scooping up peaceful protesters and
shoving them into Vans and taking
through an undisclosed location that
doesn't seem especially libertarian on
the other hand uh as I said the uh
libertarianism uh today is a coalition
between business people who want to make
a lot of money and uh these principled
Libertarians and it is the business
people uh who I think are the prevalent
part of the Coalition and I should say
I'm not casting any aspersions on
business people the ordinary business
person in a well-regulated state can
feel pretty confident that if he's
making money he's doing good for the
world because somebody is buying his
product and if he were injuring innocent
third parties somebody from the
government would come and tell him that
and tell him to stop and the fact that
nobody tells him to stop means that he
can feel like he's done a good thing in
the world with his business you will not
be able to be confident of that under
Trump trump wants you to make money
whether you hurt people or not last
thing I wanted to touch on during the
pandemic there were a lot of again
self-described Libertarians who were
saying
um the vaccines that's a problem masks a
problem what's happening in school is a
problem a problem what businesses are
having to do for this initial period of
a few months that quite frankly ended
pretty quickly all of these things are a
problem what would a sort of more
sensible but still libertarian approach
be to those issues that we saw during
the pandemic
well it's pretty simple uh the the
liberal response which I think is the
right one is if government is proposing
to restrict somebody's Liberty it's got
to have a pretty good reason sometimes
the reason s are no good uh and
sometimes the story about arrogant
government bureaucrats is correct the
Centers for Disease Control came up with
a test that didn't work and wouldn't let
anybody else develop one it was a
scandal but on the other hand uh yeah a
lot of these restrictions certainly the
massive promotion of vaccines with tax
money and the requirement that health
care workers get vaccinated uh you know
it promotes people's Liberty it keeps
them alive in fact
we have been speaking about some of the
things in Andrew koppelman's new book
out today Burning Down The House how
libertarian philosophy was corrupted by
delusion and greed we're linking to the
book and I really appreciate your time
today here it is there it is a beautiful
cover yes thanks Andrew thank you this
was great
if you value what we do at the David
packman show remember to support us on
patreon go to patreon.com davidpackman
show where you can get access to behind
the scenes videos The Daily bonus show
the commercial free Daily Show as well
as special discounts on merch including
hats hoodies mugs and t-shirts you can
support the show for as little as two
dollars a month check it out at
patreon.com davidpackman show so the
failed former president Donald Trump has
been caught in another lie thanks to
some newly released audio tapes from
related to Maggie haberman's forthcoming
book these are audio recordings of
interviews that Maggie Haberman from The
New York Times Did for this book that is
forthcoming and in this first clip that
we're going to look at Donald Trump
tells Maggie Haberman he didn't watch
the the Trump riots on January 6 2021 on
TV he wasn't watching it as it unfolded
he eventually heard about it from other
people and much later turned on the TV
just for a moment now of course we know
that this is a lie multiple Trump aides
testified before Congress under oath
that Donald Trump was watching the
entire thing and of course it's logical
that he was he went to the Capitol gave
this wacky speech people immediately
started walking to the Capitol he wanted
to go to the Capitol he was instead
brought to the White House and he sat
there watching TV the entire day but
needless to say he tries to lie here and
say no no I I wasn't that interesting no
someone had to tell me about it I was
busy doing what he hadn't been doing
work for months at that point but what
were you doing when when how did you
find out that that there were people
storming the capital I had heard that
afterwards and actually on the late side
very late very late I was I was having
meetings I was also with Mark Meadows
and others by the way the mention of
Mark Meadows makes it even less
believable because we know from from the
testimony of multiple other witnesses
that Mark Meadows was a hundred and ten
percent engaged with the riots begging
Trump to do something and in touch with
Cassidy you know all these the The
Mention Of Meadows makes this even less
believable it was already not believable
I was not watching television I did the
television okay uh I didn't usually have
that the television on I'd have it on if
there was something and of course that's
where Trump goes too far Trump had the
TV on all the time in fact he would
sometimes have it on during meetings and
it would distract him I then later
turned it on and I saw what was
happening I also had uh
confidence that
the capital who didn't want these ten
thousand people the capital police you
meant that they'd be able to control
this thing and you don't realize that
you know they they did lose control
so what Trump says there it just wasn't
true on two fronts uh that there were
AIDS around him at that time who have
testified to the house select committee
that he indeed was watching television
during that period he would have seen
the capital falling to his supporters
and also the Capitol Police were clearly
overwhelmed by the Trump supporters yeah
so it's all lies and we've we've talked
about it there's widespread reporting uh
Reuters Trump watched January 6 Capital
Riot unfold on TV ignored please to call
for peace the entire day afternoon was
Trump watching it and then initially
thinking that it was great and then
later people urging him to do something
about it Trump's starting to become
upset that the rioters were coming off
as so low brow they didn't exactly seem
like high-class people was a concern for
Trump as that was going on and we know
that it was all lie after lie after lie
now there's one other clip here this is
pretty interesting now in the context of
the Marl raid Donald Trump was asked
about by Maggie Haberman in these
recordings about taking stuff from the
White House and it's all just kind of
weird the language is weird again nation
that you had with Donald Trump where you
brought up
the correspondence he had with North
Korean leader Kim Jong and the New York
Times released audio of this now we have
audio of this conversation so let's
listen
did you leave the White House with
anything in particular are there any
Memento documents you took with you
anything
nothing of great
urgency okay I have great things there
you know the letters become letters and
many of them you were able to take those
with you look at what's happening wow
those are the love letters I think that
has the I think that's in the archives
but most of it is in the earth okay but
the Kim Jong unless we have incredible
things I have incredible letters with
other leaders
okay so at least there Donald Trump not
admitting that a whole bunch of
different stuff was taken and it was at
his house of course that interview was
from uh that interview was was from
about a year ago and uh so that is
something that is particularly
interesting at this point in time wild
stuff but even in private conversations
Trump lies because Trump lies all the
time and we know that all right this I
think you're going to love Mike pillow
is back and now he's praying for me and
he seems to have no memory that we did a
beautiful extensive interview on the
program just like I don't know a year
ago or something like that so let's kind
of go back to the beginning some of you
may remember there's this guy Mike
Lindell he's the CEO and founder of my
pillow he showed up with national a kind
of presence at the beginning of the
pandemic Donald Trump brought him to the
White House and he said oh we're going
to make masks we're going to make all
these different things and he believed
Donald Trump was selected by God and is
generally kind of a wacky guy then Mike
pillow as we know know him or just
pillow was rocketed to fame not
necessarily stardom but I guess Fame
notoriety maybe is a better word in
fighting for the overturning of the 2020
presidential election in just about
every state he claims Trump won like
California you know wacky wacky stuff
and at a certain point I interviewed him
and the interview was super interesting
I mean I don't know that we really were
convinced that indeed Trump won but it
was interesting to hear from Mike pillow
and the interview did very well on our
Channel
few weeks ago the real mic pillow showed
up on our Facebook page and started
making all sorts of allegations and
accusations against me and we went back
to him and we said Hey listen we'd love
to have you back on the program and so
far it hasn't happened well over the
weekend he showed up again in the
comments of our YouTube channel there
was a post just like a funny little post
about the bonus show it's a picture of
me with my baby daughter and I'm having
one of my globally famous and much
despised cappuccinos and it's just fun
that's all it is and the real Mike
Lindell verified account shows up and
says praying for you David you don't
know me but you sure enjoy attacking me
would love to have you on my show well
permission granted sir I would love to
be on the Mike pillow show we are trying
to get him back on our program to get
the latest updates about you know the
machines and all of this different stuff
we're doing a class
all machine
for countries have now been taken by the
machines exactly I would love to have
them back on he his his people don't
seem to be allowing him to do it or at
least not really telling him I don't
know he seems eager but they don't and I
would love to be on his program and one
of the funniest things is he seems to
genuinely have no recollection of the
fact that we do know each other we have
each other's numbers he's been on the
program we talked on the show we talked
off the show I know he's a busy guy but
you would think with the amount of time
he's spending on my Facebook page he
would have some memory of the fact that
we did a an interview and Haley actually
pointed out to him you've literally been
a guest on his show within the last year
and that is absolutely true so pillow
increasingly spending time on my
Facebook page which in a way I love and
I'm flattered and the funniest thing
about this this is like a little behind
the scenes thing
um producer Pat not long ago was trying
to get the interview booked with pillow
after he made these comments there's no
doubt that it's the real mic pillow okay
when you click it goes to his verified
page with a hundred and fifty thousand
followers this is pillow's real Facebook
account his staff said to Pat we very
much doubt that he's been commenting on
David's Facebook videos they it they
don't seem to be willing to either
accept it or look into it but it's
pillow and he's welcome on the show and
I would love to be on his show one of
the most interesting and depraved
characters of this entire Global
nightmare that has been Mega trumpism we
have a voicemail number that number is
2192 David P here's a caller saying you
know
you're still a shill
but you're the best chill
hi David this is Brad from Bloomington
Indiana right I just want to say I
always thought of you as a hill for the
past I don't know four years right uh I
gotta say
I Have Nothing changed
but I think that you're
the best show out there that's nice you
literally heal it every Sunday you're
getting better at it
sorry I said the word stuff later
okay so
um you know the funny thing about this
is I think a lot of the people using the
word chill don't really know what it
means like for me the the idea of shill
is you are some kind of an accomplice of
someone who is doing something bad
um and maybe you're even a useful idiot
and that you don't realize that you're
doing it or maybe you do yeah I don't
know all the chill stuff it's either
people think I'm a shield for the
Democratic party despite not being a
Democrat and saying so many times I
don't care about the Democratic party
the Democratic party is almost just like
a corporation whose priority is to
perpetuate its own existence if the
Democrats the better candidate I'll vote
for the Democrat I'll support the
Democrat but I don't really care about
the Democratic party some say that I am
a shill for a Socialism or communism and
of course of course I'm I'm neither a
socialist nor a communist so that one
doesn't really make a ton of sense it's
all very weird but I don't even know if
they know what it means to be a shill
but if you're gonna be a shill I'd
rather be the best and so I'll accept
the compliment I guess we have a
fantastic bonus show for you today oh
the bonus show where you want to make
money everybody else that makes money to
fund themselves is bad yeah Alex Jones
is really wound up about today's bonus
show because Russia is no longer in full
control of any of the four so-called
annexed Ukrainian provinces I don't
think Alex Jones is happy about that
we're also going to talk about the
Supreme Court rejecting a gun rights
challenge to the Banning of bump stocks
this is triggering a lot of the more
guns and more places
folks I guess I would say and Kim is it
pronounced Kardashian this is not
someone I'm familiar with she has been
charged by the that's a joke by the way
she has been charged by the SEC for
unlawfully touting a cryptocurrency scam
on her Instagram account it is explosive
and it is wild wild stuff all of these
stories and more Hyperbole and
conjecture on today's bonus show when
I'm joined by producer Pat get instant
access to the bonus show and I do mean
Instant by either signing up at
joinpakman.com or becoming a patron at
patreon.com
davidpackman show both are options to
immediately get you access to the bonus
show I hope to see you then
foreign